MUCH FOR JOINING US FOR OUR NINE
MILLION A MEETING FOR THIS IS
PROFESSIONS.
A COMMITTEE THAT CHAIR NOTICES
PRESENCE OF A REPUBLICAN MEMBER
OF AYE VICE CHAIR AND WILL BE
OPERATING AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
UNTIL EVERY HAVE A QUORUM.
AND A TURN OVER TO THE VICE
CHAIR FOR BEEF INTERACT REMARKS
[inaudible]
MISTER CHAIR.
IT'S SO NICE SUCH A KIND GESTURE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FASTER AND
YOU SPEAKER FOR ALL OF US ARE
MEMBERS OF THE OF THIS COMMITTEE
AND A VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
COMMITTEE STAFF OF THAT HELP
MAKE US.
RUN NETWORKS SO SMOOTHLY SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT
[inaudible]
OKAY.
HOME AND THE COME TO GETTING
WORSE --
THEY KEPT PLAYING THE
APPRECIATION.
OF FOR ALL OF THE COMMITTEE
STAFF SO HAVING SAID THAT
[inaudible]
YEAH.
SO HAVING SAID THAT WE WILL --
CALL UP --
FOR ITEM NUMBER ONE WHICH IS AB
FIVE A FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COME.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND
MISTER BRODY MAYBE THINK OF THE
FACT THAT THIS MAY BE THE LAST
TIME THAT ARE PRESENTING A BILL.
I'M IN A COMMITTEE IN AND OUT OF
THE ASSEMBLY SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT REMINDER AND I APPRECIATE
ALL OF THE HARD WORK THAT YOU
ALL DO SO.
IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE HERE TODAY
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT AB FIVE
OH FIVE WHICH WOULD AUTHORIZED
AN ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE TO
EXTEND.
THE TIME FOR DISCLOSURE AN
EXPERT WITNESS IN MATTERS
BROUGHT BEFORE THE MEDICAL BOARD
OF CALIFORNIA.
THE EXPERT REVIEWER PROGRAM WAS
ESTABLISHED BY THE MEDICAL BOARD
IN NINETEEN NINETY FOUR FOR THE
PURPOSE OF SUPPORTING
INVESTIGATIONS BEING HEARD BY
THE BOARD.
THESE MEDICAL EXPERTS PROVIDE
EXPERT TESTIMONY RELATIVE TO THE
CASE AS WELL AS CON.
CONDUCT PROFESSIONAL COMPETENCY
MEDICAL AND PSYCHIATRIC EXAMS
BOTH SIDES OF THE CASE ARE PRIVY
TO TO BE INFORMATION REGARDING
THE EXPERT WITNESSES IN AN
EFFORT TO ENSURE THAT THE
WITNESS IS QUALIFIED.
THE INFORMATION IS COMPILED IN
THE FORM OF REPORTS FORMS AND
STATEMENTS REGARDING THE
WITNESSES CREDENTIALS AND
OPINIONS ON THE CASE AT HAND.
HOWEVER CURRENT LAW REQUIRES
THIS INFORMATION TO BE PROVIDED
TO THE OTHER PART PARTY WITHIN
THIRTY DAYS PRIOR TO THE
SCHEDULED HEARING WHICH CAN BE
DIFFICULT TO COMPLETE GIVEN ALL
OF THE REQUIREMENTS.
AB FIVE OH FIVE SIMPLY INCREASES
THE TIME FRAME FROM THIRTY TWO
HUNDRED DAYS BASED ON A SHOWING
OF GOOD CAUSE AND SUBJECT TO THE
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE JUDGE'S
APPROVAL.
THIS ADDITIONAL TYPE HEARD WILL
ENSURE BOTH PARTIES IN THE CASE
HAVE ADEQUATE TIME TO PREPARE
FOR AN EXPERT WITNESS TO
TESTIFY.
WHICH IS VITAL TO PROTECTING THE
RIGHTS OF DUE PROCESS STANDARD
OBVIOUSLY WHICH WE ALL EXPECT
THE JUDICIAL SYSTEM TO COMPLY
WITH.
IN SUPPORT OF FAIR TREATMENT IN
CASES HEARD BY THE MEDICAL BOARD
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY ONE
COVER ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM. FOR THE AUTHOR --
IT'S AN ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
MORNING MR CHEN MEMBERS MAKE IT
ALRIGHT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
THE SPONSOR OF THIS BILL.
I'VE I WON'T SPEAK AT LENGTH
BECAUSE THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN
REALLY COVERED IT ALL BUT I JUST
APPRECIATE ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS
DISCUSSIONS GOING INTO THIS
BILL.
AND WE REALLY BELIEVE THAT AB
FIVE OF FIVE AS STRIKES THE
CORRECT BALANCE BETWEEN
INTERESTS WITHOUT OVER BURDENING
DEFENDED POSITIONS.
AND IS A GREAT.
CAN FIX TO IT SOME UNFORESEEN
ISSUES OF LAST [inaudible]
PORT.
IN ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT AND WE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
NO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ANY
FINAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR
THE AUTHOR AT THIS TIME.
TINO QUESTION COMES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COVERED YOU WISH TO
CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THINKING GREEN YOU VERY
MUCH AND WE'LL REVISIT THIS
ISSUE WHEN WE REACH COR THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WONDERFUL SO NEXT DOUBLE GOATS
AND THAT ASIDE IN ORDER FOR A
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE WHICH IS
AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN THIS AREA.
OKAY COMPETITIVE THIS MORNING TO
SIGN AN GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY THREE WILL
GUARANTEE THAT CONSUMERS PAY THE
LOWEST AVAILABLE COST FOR THEIR
PRESCRIPTIONS SENATE AMENDMENTS
REQUIRE PHARMACY TED TELEKI
SUMER WHEN THE RETAIL PRICE FOR
A COVERED PRESCRIPTION DRUG.
IS LOWER THAN THE RATE
NEGOTIATED BY THEIR HEALTH PLAN.
IF THE CUSTOMER PAYS THE RETAIL
PRICE THE PHARMACY MUST SUBMIT
THE CLAIM TO THE HEALTH PLAN OR
INSURER SO THAT IT CAN BE
APPLIED. TO THE CUSTOMER'S
DEDUCTIBLE AND MAXIMUM OUT OF
POCKET COSTS.
AS IF THEY HAD PAID THE COST
SHARING AMOUNT.
AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY THREE HAS
NO OPPOSITION AND HAS RECEIVED
NO NO VOTES.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHERE I
VOTE AND I'M JOINED BY SOME
WONDERFUL PEOPLE HERE
[inaudible]
PLEASE WELCOME.
HI GOOD MORNING SHEILA'S WITH
CROWLEY WITH THE SAME CALIFORNIA
CHRONIC CARE COALITION THE
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL.
THIS BILL IS PARTICULARLY
IMPORTANT TO THE PATIENTS
REPRESENTED.
BY REMEMBER GROUPS AS PEOPLE
WITH CHRONIC CONDITIONS OFTEN
HELP MORE THAN ONE CHRONIC
CONDITION AND ARE OFTEN ON
MULTIPLE MEDICATIONS.
SO THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
COPAYS AND IF THERE'S A LOWER.
A RETAIL PRICE CAN BE VERY
SIGNIFICANT FOR THIS POPULATION
SO WE APPRECIATE OF THE AUTHOR
--
OFFERING THIS AND WOULD
APPRECIATE LIFE OF THANK YOU.
MR MEMBERS TO MEN REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA RHEUMATOLOGY ALLIANCE
IN SUPPORT FOR THE REASONS
STATED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WHICH IS
BEGIN SUPPORT NAME AFFILIATION
IF YOU WISH TO DO SO.
JOHN WINGER ON BEHALF ANTHEM
BLUE CROSS AMERICA'S HEALTH
INSURANCE PLANS AND EXPRESS
GROUPS ON SUPPORT.
KNEELING BIJAN WITH MCCUE
CAPTAIN ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
LIFE AND HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES AND SUPPORT.
FACE LAING BORDERS OF CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH
UNDERWRITERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
SEE NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMEMORATIVE THIS TIME
ASSEMBLYMAN IS THERE AND YOU
WISH TO CLOSE.
I RESPECT LESS RAVEL THINK YOU
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
AGAIN WE WOULD BE THIS THIS
ISSUE WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NO -- AND
SIGNED IN ORDER FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR WHICH IS AB TWENTY EIGHT
NINETY NINE BY SOME REMEMBER
RUBIO [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING I TURNED MEMBERS AT
TODAY I'M PRESENTING ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY EIGHT NINETY NINE
WHICH PROHIBITS A LICENSEE FOR
FROM A PUBLISHING AND OR
DISSEMINATING ADVERTISING OR
MARKETING.
WHILE THE LICENSEES LICENSE IS
SUSPENDED WE TAKE AMENDMENTS IN
THE SENATE TO FOCUS ON
ADDRESSING SUSPENDED LICENSES
BEING ADVERTISED.
THE LEGISLATION IS A SMALL STEP
FORWARD THAT WILL HELP.
UP PROPERLY REGULATE LICENSEES
AND THERE BUT BUSINESS
ACTIVITIES --
THIS IS ALL RELATED TO CANNABIS
ADVERTISE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF SOMEONE
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING
TO SPEAK SUPPORT.
SEEM NO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
AND WHAT IS AN OPPOSITION ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM CAN
YOU MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
I DON'T SEE NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM KEY MEMBERS OF
SOME A RUBIO.
THANK YOU I JUST RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR IBOOK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND AGAIN WE WILL
REVISIT THIS ISSUE IN WE REACH A
QUORUM THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THAT'S OUR FINAL ITEM WHICH IS A
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TWO AB FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOOKING.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS BILL IZAKAYA SECOND
OF A TWO PART SERIES OF BILLS
LAST YEAR WE AUTHORED A A LIE
ABOUT TIME MAKING SURE THAT.
PSYCHOLOGISTS HAD --
TRAINING IN SUICIDE PREVENTION
THIS BILL EXTENDS THAT TWO OF
BEHAVIORAL THERAPIST AS WELL
OURSELF THAT'S RIGHT UP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND IT IS AN
OASIS IN SUPPORT.
PAGE ON US WITH THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE WE'RE VERY PROUD TO
SPONSOR THIS LEGISLATION AND
ALSO TO PARTNER AGAIN WITH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE ON THIS
VERY IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THANK YOU.
YOU VERY MUCH.
WITNESS GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS WHO SHALL MUCH
LOBBY HAVE TO CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION AND SOME.
ROSEANNE HELMS ON BEHALF OF THE
BOARD OF BEHAVIORAL SCIENCES AND
THE BOARD IS IN SUPPORT.
JV HEIRS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR LICENSED
PROFESSIONAL CLINICAL
COUNSELORS.
WE BELIEVE THAT THE RISKS
INVOLVED IN SUICIDE IS SO GREAT
THAT.
IN AN OVER ABUNDANCE OF CAUTION
WE ARE IN SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL BONUSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
HE CAN RUN ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
NO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMENCE AT THIS
TIME DOCTOR I I THINK YOU DON'T
THINK MISTER LEVINE FURNACE OUT.
HIS ARTHRITIS INTEREST IN THIS
TOPIC A BUT LIKE LAST YEAR I
WILL BE AT NOT SUPPORTING THIS
BILL -- AND
I APPRECIATE THAT YOUR FEELINGS
THAT TRAINED PROFESSIONALS NEED
MORE TRAINING --
BUT I WOULD SAY THAT OUR
CURRICULUM IN GRADUATE PROGRAMS
--
IS PRETTY ESTABLISHED THE WIDEST
WHAT PEOPLE NEED.
AYE IN COURSEWORK AND THEN FOR
LICENSURE PURPOSES --
AND I APPRECIATE THE SHERIFFS
ARE IN -- IN
SUPPORT AS WELL BECAUSE
OFTENTIMES SO BECAUSE I THINK
YOU'RE USING THE IDEA THAT
PEOPLE WHO ARE DEPRESSED HAVE
SEEN SOME KIND OF A POTENTIALLY
THERAPIST IN OF IN THE TIME
BEFORE.
IT'S A ULTIMATELY I DO TAKE
THEIR LIFE --
BUT I WOULD OFFER THAT GAP I
MEAN.
IT'S LIKE SAYING THAT PEOPLE GET
IN MORE WRECKS CLOSE TO THEIR
HOME --
BECAUSE THAT IS IN THEM MOST
CLOSE PROXIMITY TO WHAT THEY'RE
DOING --
OFTENTIMES OTHER PEOPLE SUCH AS
EMERGENCY ROOM PROFESSIONALS
SHERIFFS POLICE OFFICERS A LOT
OF OTHER PEOPLE ALSO COME IN
CONTACT WITH FOLKS WHO EVENT NO
TRAINING WHATSOEVER --
SO BUT AGAIN I APPRECIATE YOUR
INTENSE INTEREST IN THIS --
BUT I DO BELIEVE THAT PROFESSION
--
CAN CAN PROVIDE THE CURRICULUM
THAT PROFESSIONALS LAY OUT A THE
DREAMS ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
COMES FROM CAN MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME.
SEEING NONE ASSEMBLY WE'RE
LOOKING TO PUSH TO CLOSE HERSELF
OFF FROM AYE VOTE GREAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
AND WE WILL --
ESTABLISH A QUORUM SO CONSIDER
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
CLUB.
HERE BROKE CARE ARAMBULA
[inaudible]
BAKER [inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
CHEN [inaudible]
JILL [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
IRWIN [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
TING.
OKAY WE'VE NOW ESTABLISHED CORMS
AND NOW ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
SHOULD THERE BE AN INTEREST
[inaudible]
THE MOTION.
OKAY DESERT MOTION AND A SECOND
PRETTY SECTOR BUT PLEASE
CULTURAL.
SENATE MINUTES THREE CONCURRED
IN LOW AYE LOW AYE BRO.
WE'RE NOT HURTING ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BAKER AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHAN CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM EGGMAN.
EGGMAN NO FALL.
FONG I GIPSON.
GRAYSON.
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MCCARTY.
MEDINA MEDINA AYE MULLIN
OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NOTING [inaudible]
TING AYE.
IT WILL KEEP THEIR OPEN FOR
ABSENT.
THANK YOU ARE MY TAKE YOU VERY
MUCH.
OKAY THE MOTION.
FOR MOVING OF FILES ON MY OWN.
THEY'VE BEEN A SECOND.
SEC PLEASE HOLD WHILE.
SENATE BENNETT STICKING CARD AND
LOW AYE FLOW AYE BRO PRO AYE
ARAMBULA.
BAKER BAKER AYE BLOOM.
LOU I CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN IPHONE FONG AYE GIPSON.
GRAYSON [inaudible]
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MCCARTY.
MEDINA MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE TING
[inaudible]
TING AYE.
THOSE ARE TWELVE VOTES WON'T
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN [inaudible]
FOR MEMBERS [inaudible]
RECYCLING GOOGLE.
SENATE MINISTRY CONCURRED AND
LOW AYE LOW EYEBROW.
BROKE I ARAMBULA.
BAKER BAKER AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM I CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I FALL FONG AYE GIPSON.
GRAYSON.
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MCCARTY.
MEDINA MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE TING
[inaudible]
TING AYE [inaudible] TWO VOTES.
THE ROLE FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
IS THERE A SECOND [inaudible]
OKAY.
SENATE MINUTES TO BE KINCARDINE
LOW HIGH LOW AYE BRO.
BRO I ARAMBULA.
BAKER BAKER AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
EGGMAN IPHONE.
FONG I GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
WHEN I MCCARTY?
MEDINA MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE TING.
TING AYE. FOURTEEN OF THEM
BELIEVE THE ROLE OF CONTRACTING
MEMBERS AND AGAIN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH VICE CHAIR BUFFER COMMENTS
EARLIER WITH RESPECT TO
APPRECIATE HIM STAFF WOULD YOU
WILL LIKELY HAVE ADDITIONAL.
A COMMITTEE HEARING OFF THE
FLOOR BUT JUST AS AN FYI SOAPS
AND HAVING SAID THAT WE SEE
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS WHO HAVE ALSO
ARRIVE SO COMMITTED TO WHAT YOU
[inaudible]
OF GO OVER THE ROLE AGAIN AND
WE'LL START DOWN WITH --
AND FILE ORDER FILE AND ONE
EIGHTY FIVE FIVE AB FIVE OH FIVE
SEVEN MINUTES TO BE CONCURRED IN
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE CHU.
CHU AYE CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible] FOURTEEN ZERO
THE BILL IS OUT
.
FATIMAH CHIU A. B..
FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX AB FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX SEVEN MINUTES
WEAKENED HEARD IN ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE CHU CHU AYE
CUNNINGHAM.
GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
MULLIN.
SO THE TO THAT VILLAGE OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
THREE AB.
TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY THREE AB
TWENTY SIX TWO THREE SEVEN
MINUTES TAKEN HEARD AND
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE CHU CHU AYE
CUNNINGHAM.
GIPSON GIPSON AYE GRAYSON
[inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
MULLIN.
JUNE ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT AND
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB.
TWENTY EIGHT NINETY NINE AB TWO
EIGHT NINE NINE SEVEN MINUTES WE
CAN CARD IN ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE CUNNINGHAM
[inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
MULLIN.
IN THIS YEAR THAT BILL IS OUT.
OKAY IT WILL HOLD THE ROLE BEEN
FOR ADDITIONAL TWO MINUTES
.
AB FIVE A FIVE SEVEN MINUTES
SPEAKING HEARD AND GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE.
AB FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX SEVEN
MINUTES WE CAN GUARD AND
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE.
AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY THREE
SENTIMENTS WE CONCURRED AND
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE.
AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETY NINE
SENATE MINUTES WECONCURRED AND
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE
[inaudible]
YES YES.
WITH ONE OF
I HAVE
.
YEAH IT'S WORTH.
YOU TABLE.
BLACK.
OKAY PANDA COMPETITIVE YOU WHO
COULD GO THROUGH THE ROLE ONE A
FINAL TIME AND THEN WE'LL CLOSE
ROLE.
AB FIVE FIVE SENTIMENT SPEAKER
KURT AND MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM I OKAY THE USER THOSE
OUT.
AB FOURTEEN THIRTY SIX SEVEN
MINUTES WE CONCURRED AND COMING
UP.
CUNNINGHAM AYE MCCARTY
[inaudible]
MCCARTY I WITHOUT.
AB TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY THREE
SEVEN MINUTES TO BE CONCURRED
AND CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY
AYE.
A TWO ZERO THAT PHYLLIS OUT.
AB TWENTY EIGHT NINETY NINE
SEVEN MINUTES TO BE CONQUERED
AND CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. MCCARTY MCCARTY
AYE.
DESERVE THE BILL IS OUT.
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TURN
.
YEAH WE'D LOVE IT IF I THINK
[inaudible]
OFTEN